bitcoin mining difficulty nice little
pink line here what's it showing us yeah
so uh this whole kind of slide deck is
just i've heard a lot of buzz about
publicly traded bitcoin miners and so i
think you know what we really want to do
here is is if you're buying publicly
traded minor stocks or evaluating them
how are you actually evaluating the
performance so right here we have mining
difficulty and this is in log scale so
if you look at a linear scale it's
basically uh it doesn't look like
it looked like it was at zero until like
2020 and then all of a sudden just
went parabolic upwards but in in log
scale
mining difficulty is appreciated by
you know i think like 10 orders of
magnitude or something outrageous uh you
know as bitcoin mining went from just
doing it on cpus where you could mine 50
bitcoin
just on your old crappy laptop to now
you know these just an unbelievable
amount of hashing power all over the
world so understanding mining difficulty
and how basically bitcoin supply and
elasticity works where every commodity
in the world as it gets more expensive
than sent to produce it obviously
increases
but with bitcoin there's a difficulty
adjustment so uh as it gets more
lucrative to produce to mine
it becomes incrementally that much
harder uh to get the thing and so it's
unlike any asset in the world in that
sense and i think it's really important
to understand that uh if you're going
into the business of bitcoin mining or
buying these miners all right next we've
got hash rate here uh which also seems
to just be going up along with obviously
the difficulty but uh is there any end
in sight for uh for hashrate yeah so i
mean essentially this is the same chart
uh difficulty is basically um there's
there's a ten there's a ten minute block
target over at that 200 i'm sorry 2016
uh block interval right so uh every 2016
blocks uh if blocks are coming in faster
than that 10-minute interval then
difficulty will adjust upwards and and
likewise if it's slower than that
10-minute target then it'll adjust
downwards so this is showing the same
chart but hash rate is derived by
basically how fast blocks are coming in
relative to how difficult it is to mine
blocks
all right mining difficulty and hash
rate when you look at this this is just
literally overlaying them on top of each
other for the most part yeah this is
just uh this is in linear terms and this
is just the last uh two years just for
some uh
you know just for a visual graphic okay
then we've got hash price which is the
minor revenue per terra hash what is
this showing us
yeah so this is uh that same chart over
time and this is in us dollars so as
bitcoins appreciated um you know a bunch
similar to how hash rate has risen
but you kind of see basically and this
is in log scale but over time a marginal
unit of of hash rate gets you less and
less uh in terms of dollars as as rate
continues to just go exponential and so
what you kind of see is that uh you know
a lot of these inefficient rigs over
time
have to get plugged into more and more
efficient uh uses of that energy to stay
competitive and so it's kind of this
darwinistic process where uh you know
basically the revenue is is trending to
zero in bitcoin terms and that's what
we're going to show in the next one but
this one is in usd terps it's just
pretty crazy how much uh hash rate
continues to to increase over time all
right then we've got hash price the
amount of revenue per terra hash in this
uh this next chart
yep and so this is uh this is just an
up-close uh view of the same thing and
this is in linear terms and so this is
uh dollar denominated but basically what
you can see is and if you look
closely to say may of 2020 you see
basically a vertical line down uh that
is the having event and so uh if you
tend to look at a lot of publicly traded
miners uh basically in bitcoin terms
what you'll see is that they trade out
of multiple
or pretty closely to this to this metric
here because uh hash price is taking
that minor revenue it's dividing it by
by the hash rate so as hash rate
increases uh it is basically the profit
margins for a lot of these miners
compress
got it then we've got uh more of the
having's kind of zoomed out here you can
see three halvings on this next graphic
and basically that's really what's
helping to drive this down over time
yeah so this is that same hash price
metric but it's denominating in btc
terms um so when i say i say things on
twitter a lot like uh basically it's
it's the production price of bitcoin the
cost to produce a marginal satoshi is
going is trending towards infinity and
basically what this means is hash rates
essentially there's an economic
incentive crash rate to increase forever
um if you factor in moore's law
basically um you know processing power
computing powers is increasing
exponential terms uh as well as you know
just there's this huge economic
incentive to monetize wasted energy
resources all over the world uh what you
see here is that along with the havings
and the difficulty adjustments if you
look very very closely you'll see kind
of it's like a step function all the way
down in this chart and that's every time
difficulty increases or there's a having
event where you can really see it uh it
becomes that much more difficult uh to
mine a unit of bitcoin or satoshi uh and
so uh this is really key to evaluating
publicly traded miners or uh you know
bitcoin bitcoin mining in general and
we're kind of working your way in to see
some of these charts in bitcoin terms
okay and then if we go ahead and we go
to the next chart here this is i think
just to having zoomed in where you can
see a very significant drop uh in a in a
single one um
when you look at this uh what exactly is
uh is this showing uh in terms of uh on
on this graphic here
yeah so i've kind of put a lot of
similar charts in this slide deck but
really what i'm trying to show is uh
with a mix of linear and logarithmic
scale just just you know how how fast uh
this ecosystem is moving so this chart
is in linear terms and what it's showing
is basically how much bitcoin a margin
of the unit of hash rate or a terra hash
can get you um so if you know if you
plug in an asic what can you expect for
revenue and what you can basically see
is since since 2017 since the top it's
become uh unbelievably more difficult to
mine bitcoin uh you know per unit of
hash rate and so and you can see that
kind of that having there there was a
decrease of 50
and so uh when you look at a lot of
these publicly traded mining charts and
btc terms uh i think you'll notice you
know you'll notice something pretty
staggering and it might look a lot like
this chart
got it and then this last one here uh
around the uh the hash rate uh this is
the zoomed in on the having drop uh
that's pretty significant when you zoom
in on it is that something that we
should expect every single time there's
a having
yeah so this is minor revenue upper hash
and btc terms and so what you can see
here is a lot of the variance and and
the kind of the those those step
functions are that's difficulty and hash
rate and you can see um some of the
things like the minor capitulation and
with difficulty had this huge downwards
adjustment that's that spike you see
kind of in in july where it actually
became a lot more profitable for any
miners that were able to remain plugged
in
but yeah this is this is in btc terms
and every having you can expect going
forward eventually uh fees will will
make up a dominant majority of of the
minor revenue but for now um you know
fees as a percent of minor revenue is
still one to two percent and that block
subsidy uh currently at six point two
five every every ten minutes or every
block uh makes up a uh dominant share of
the minor revenue
all right now uh these next charts are
uh are gonna be fun uh
we've got riot
denominated in btc riot being the
publicly traded uh mining organization
we have mara hutt
bitf
and hive basically you've got five of
them here what are you one trying to
show and then we can kind of click
through each one of them as as we go but
uh they're all down against bitcoin um
and so what exactly are you trying to uh
to show here
yeah i'm not not trying to discourage
anybody from buying mining uh mining
stocks i have no affiliation with any of
these companies i don't really have an
agenda all because you know the sharks
that i was showing earlier we're really
trying to do one thing it's trying to
get people to think in a bitcoin
standard um and so you know a lot of
these if you look at a lot of these
companies especially over the last uh
last two years or since say the bear
market in 2018 in usd terms they're
they're up a huge amount um but
especially since before the 2017 bull
run or say you know at the bottom of
2020 if you're looking at a lot of these
uh companies in btc terms uh they're
down almost you know some of them 90 90
plus um and this is because um if you're
evaluating these companies uh and their
valuations in in bitcoin terms uh the
the fact is the fact of the matter is
that basically their their revenue um
and if they increase their hash rate
they can attempt to keep pace but the
revenue in bitcoin terms is essentially
programmed to go down forever uh
basically all mining star in in bitcoin
terms and so um you know playing with
publicly traded miners investing in them
allocating in them
is totally fine and you know i encourage
people to do their own research but at
the end of the day is you know a lot of
this performance is is somewhat expected
if you kind of understand the economics
of bitcoin mining um and so the
companies that kind of hyper bitcoinize
their balance sheets the best uh we'll
we'll keep up you know say michael
saylor and microstrategy since since
adopting a bitcoin standard i think are
slightly underperforming bitcoin itself
uh and that and their balance sheet is
essentially 100 bitcoin now
but a lot of these companies
you know they're they're buying a bunch
of asics are trying to plug them in uh
and since they're say ipo or just you
know i chose three four year time frames
for a lot of these companies um they're
underperforming bitcoin by a wide margin
because in usd terms the revenues
increase it and they're growing and
they're growing fast but in btc terms
their revenue is decreasing
programmatically so because of the
having and the difficulty adjustments um
so these are just some things to kind of
consider when you're evaluating uh say
investing in mining companies or or even
you know any company really uh it's just
you know the fact of the matter is it's
going to get uh it's programmed to
become you know uh to produce a marginal
unit of bitcoin it's gonna get harder
forever if hash rate continues increase
so uh you know just some just some ideas
got it and so when you think about
denomination in bitcoin obviously uh
denominating stocks in bitcoin uh like
this are uh are pretty eye-opening uh if
you were to do this for the s p 500 if
you were to do this for nasdaq etc let's
say in 2021 all of them are down against
bitcoin and that's just a function of
bitcoin was up you know 65 percent they
weren't and so naturally uh that
denomination ends up looking like it's
just down uh do you think that
professional investors kind of um not
the the retail crowd not the uh bitcoin
crowd but wall street firms or hedge
funds uh big banks like eventually do
they start to change the way that they
actually denominate uh these investments
as well or do you think they're so kind
of codified into the the fiat
mentality and the denomination in
dollars that they stay uh without
looking at it this way
yeah i think it's pretty standard for
like say a lot of fund managers to get
you know
benchmark to the s p or to the nasdaq or
just you know to it to a standard basket
of equities and i think it's going to be
increasingly common for a lot of these
managers as bitcoin becomes you know
it's already kind of entrenched itself
as a macro asset but i think you know
over the 2022 over the next you know say
four years or decade really uh what
you're going to see is bitcoin itself
becomes a benchmark um and i don't
expect the volatility to completely go
away i actually expect uh volatility to
persist for for the most part but i
think the reality is as this asset class
grows in relevance and kind of
acceptance uh it's going to be kind of a
benchmark to say you know why would i
give you any money or why would i invest
in your company when i can just buy this
thing and outperform you know almost
everything and so uh whether that's for
you know publicly traded miners or
whether that's for uh hedge funds and
their performance um you know if if a
simple retail investor can go go buy
bitcoin and outperform you uh and a lot
of times with bitcoin you know not in
2021 with so much volatility but through
most of bitcoin's history it was the
best uh in invol adjusted or uh in
risk-adjusted terms it was the best
performing asset as well and so uh it'll
be interesting to see how it all plays
out but i think bitcoin increasingly
becomes a benchmark
for performance for all of wall street
and investors in general